- What's up there, chef, how you doing?
(gasps) Oh, my gosh!
- Again.
- Do not do this to me!
I so want another child and my husband
is like, "No, we have four!"
Oh my gosh, so, oh, so cute.
I know this is a weird statement,
but I kinda wanna eat your baby,
it's so cute (laughs).
Alright, you're kind of
always near a kitchen.
Are you near your kitchen right now?
- I am, I'll quickly take you in there,
because this is the sort of, the hot zone.
So, let me show you.
It's all nice and clean, 'cause
I've cleaned the thing up.
In fact, there's two
areas of the kitchen here.
There's that little bit now, over here,
so she has what they call an amazing Aga.
Oh, and look, look who's
sat in front (laughs).
- Oh my gosh, so adorable,
do not do this, I have baby fever.
I want a little baby.
Oh my god.
- [Gordon] And then, Tan?
- [Tan] Yeah.
- [Gordon] What is this,
what is this over here?
This is Oscar's dinner.
- [Tan] It's sweet potato, and
there's veggies in the pan.
- Oh, it's sweet potato, and
veggies for Oscar's dinner.
- She's, veggie from the
can, oh, I love your accent.
I wish I could eat your baby (laughs).
Your baby eats better than me.
- I want another one, too,
and I have five, it's crazy.
- Six?
- Yeah.
- What, seriously?
Oscar, Oscar, look, he's in the kitchen
with his pots and pans.
- I'm just saying, you get baby fever
when you see them, and you're like,
"Oh, I miss the chubby little
legs, and the little face."